okay so here we are this is eating your
feed my name is Nikki today my friend
Adam is challenging me to make macarons
shaped as corn to use its this shop
called honey and butter in Irvine
California that makes a bunch of
different types of macarons one of them
is this thing called a unicorn e a union
party is a Corgi with a unicorn horn
it looks really easy based off of the
video because it shows her just like
piping the shape of a corgi and then
they fill it with like what looks like a
chocolaty filling and they kind of just
pop it right on top everyone was never
made macarons and I've never made any
type of food in the shape of an animal
before as always today very talented
tasty chef producer RIA is here how hard
is it really in my opinion it's one of
the most difficult this R to make so you
just need a practice the feet of a
macaron is when the cookie rises and so
that's like an important mark of a
macaron yeah so if you don't have feet
that's a bad macro great if I struggle
you call okay I found a tasty recepies
I'm gonna just make regular circular
macarons first and then if that goes
well I will graduate to the unicorn look
out world what if I'm so good at this so
I printed out a template I've seen other
people use it when they like pipe it out
so that it's relatively the same size
and shape so that's underneath a piece
of like baking paper 200 grams of
powdered sugar 110 grams of almond flour
I need a hundred grams of egg whites
shibam stripe city population me 50
grams of sugar for my meringue big bowl
an important thing is that the almond
flour and the powdered sugar are as fine
as possible so way people do that is to
throw it in the food processor good
oh yeah this is gonna be fine so I'm
gonna make my meringue which is like the
base for this cookie
well splurge of tarter and I'm just
gonna whip them that will give us like
the firmness and structure for this
light and fluffy cookie what a weird
thing these things come out of chickens
oh that looks pretty stiff oh what's
that thing you can link a lift it over
your head and it doesn't come out that
means it's ready good really myself over
this morning
whoo and I guess it's just all of it
that all goes in we're not doing any
food coloring these are just gonna be
plain my crusts and now we fold don't
overmix don't under mix we want to get
it to like a ribbony consistency so that
it is fluidy
it like holds its shape Wow these were
very stiff peaks I'm gonna go a little
bit more yeah that's a kind of an a I'm
gonna sound mixed thing I think we got
it I'm gonna be baking with a convection
oven which like blows hot air throughout
so you don't want any paper flapping
back and forth so I'm just using a
little bit of the batter that kind of
like spilled over and I'm putting it on
the corner of my baking paper so that it
stays down know how much experience
piping but when I was like a kid and
watching people bake it was always like
the most appealing part of it that's
coming out was I not supposed to cut the
bag until the stuff was in these look
relatively close to each other okay
there's like a tapping thing that I have
to do to kind of get rid of all of these
little air bubbles that you can see so
now I have to let it rest for like 30
minutes I don't know why so what we want
to check is that there's like a smooth
film that has created on the top layer
so when I touch it it shouldn't like
indent oh yeah three solid 285 for about
15 minutes
oh man it's flapping okay so it's been
15 minutes when I take them out now so
they do have
eat its little okay so these are cooled
ooh you're sticking a little Wow you're
a little underdone
uh-huh so I'm gonna try regular macarons
again because the consistency of these
there's no way I would have been able to
pipe a corgi that's number two I think
the recipe was spot-on I don't think I
need to change a whole lot there it was
just really the mixing and the bake time
we're still ready to sift in the flour
and sugar so I've got red and yellow
food going to make hopefully an orange
II corgi color I am being tested this is
weird
are we sure this is food coloring let's
sleep icing right yeah this is just I
found Orange well a little bit of that
stuff goes along way it's a little thick
still but here's where I got to be real
careful I'm gonna stop all right a
little making a mess this already looks
better okay
definitely more pipeable those are gonna
set for 30 minutes
I have batter left over should I try
making shapes I'm an expert the Corgi
kind of had a big ish so it's kind of a
funky ear all corgis are different oh
what a disaster I also think my orange
is a little too Payable we are making
improvements okay let's go
all right so we have feet got nice round
edges I think I definitely got more of a
rise out of these I think I still
overmixed which is crazy
I definitely need more orange these
corgis are pretty pale this is like
human flesh color I think I'm gonna make
a filling I think what I'm gonna do is a
ganache and I learned how to make
ganache when I make the crepe cake I'm
gonna do a one to one ratio of a
chocolate to a cream cool whoa hot cream
over chocolate and then that's going to
sit for about 30 seconds and then I mix
it I think it's gonna thicken as it
cools get it to room temperature in the
hall
all right oh that does not look half bad
not delicate at all I don't know if it's
like I haven't let them cool enough ya
know what it is I'm baked after you bake
peel one and a big stick in the paper
that is under baked but these feet are
better right mm-hmm
long enough it's too wet did you put it
in your refrigerator no maybe that's why
day to macaron so Rio said my last batch
were under baked so I got to do a better
job getting them baked properly I also
realize that these are like gluten free
dairy free cookies underground hangar
super fine we're not going to over mix
this shredder counting
and we want to do a little more than I
did last time eleven twelve thirty five
feels good my instinct is to go a little
bit more but I think that's what I did
last time this is it this is definitely
more orange than last time I'm gonna
continue to make the little circle
cookies here just to make sure I can get
a good bake on that and then whatever
leftover batter I have I'll practice
some piping corgis all right so the
batter is gonna set and then we'll be
ready to bake and I think the corgis are
gonna have to bake longer than the
little ones pretty stable there let's go
Ivan time free a recommended taking them
out and seeing if it'll peel off
relatively easy
that means it's completely baked I'm
gonna go test one see where we're at I
think it's okay I'm gonna let them sit
and dry I turned the oven off I've left
the microns in there with the door open
a little bit so that it will dry out the
ganache yesterday wasn't quite the right
consistency so I'm gonna go for more of
a buttercream chocolate buttercream and
essentially butter half a tablespoon of
vanilla no maybe my butter should have
been a little soft that's creamy more
powdered sugar quarter cup of cocoa
powder so I put in one tablespoon of
milk and just a little more so I'm just
slowly incorporating all of the
ingredients it tastes good and it looks
like a good buttercream and it's gonna
be like a sweetheart attack so it's been
30 ish minutes baby
ah yeah let's see how these boys look oh
yeah look at that I gotta go to the
buttercream cuz I'm gonna put these on
them this is a poopy little Corgi poop
it works I made a sandwich cookie should
I give this little doggy poopy eyes just
like the video
these aren't perfectly shaped but I have
a top and I have a bottom hmm
now the unit Cory I'm gonna make two
batters one just orange let's make some
ears I have to make another batch now I
need a white black and red I'm gonna try
and mix it and then split it up oh well
this is gonna be very boy that's okay oh
yeah it's a good read three colors okay
I got my Corgi face up right on the ears
and a unicorn horn a line down the
middle
nice big ol eyeballs and oval for the
mouth not looking too bad all right I
got a lot of work to do you need their
white eye dots
my first one is definitely the best
really just kind of went downhill from
here okay it's been roughly 30 minutes
these corgis have set and they are ready
to bake look at this
ear it lifted we're good alright put
them back in the dry I realized that one
tray is completely missing the one white
IDOT so I really only have one tray of
viable not Quran corgis I think you've
got at least one good one in there I
think they're done and I'm gonna go get
him UNICOR d man I really hope they peel
off oh yeah I'm really worried that
bowtie is just completely gonna break
off and the horn
just don't wait for home break break oh
I'm squishing it
hey Yoona corby check it out I'm really
surprised especially alright buttercream
oh no I shouldn't but it in the Bridget
can i warm it up stand by my buttercream
was too cold I microwaved it thirty
seconds and it's nice and soft
you look like bellies that wasn't great
obviously not enough roasting on that
side it looks like doggy poo I think I
did some good-lookin ears waver ear and
then the other the bowties a little bit
blobby
but he's got a good unicorn horn and
he's gonna keep face let's tell me hey
did you go to the store to vote and no I
didn't I made these do you didn't think
I could do it
to be honest you can be honest I was so
surprised can I eat it
yeah let's eat one note sternos nice
like inside it kind of chewy mm-hmm
outside is crispy
is just so sweet mm-hmm I'm just so good
no one thought I could do it alright so
I figured out how to make a good macaron
and I figured out how to pipe them in
the shape of corgis and get a good bake
on them I made a chocolate buttercream
filling okay this is the closest I've
ever gotten to like nailing a video took
me two days to be able to make three
that look kind of okay the restaurant
has like tons of these to sell which is
really really cool I think you'll know
that Wow I'm gonna put this on my resume
I can make a unicorn game macarons
oh yes
[Music]
you